die schaufel ist ein sprecher von hier
kommt meist noch ein bisschen verliebte
paare letzten bezeichnungen
geheimrezepte oder nach geheimrezept
ich weiß genau und herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video ich hoffe
natürlich euch jetzt gut ich freue mich
heute besonders wir haben gerade 10 39
und heute startet ein format auf das ich
mich sehr freue ich kann das ganze schon
ein bisschen länger und heute drehen
für folge eins und zwar ist es ja ich
wohne in köln ich wohne jetzt so
ungefähr zwei jahre oder so und ich habe
in diesen zwei jahren hier schon
verdammt viele das für uns ausprobiert
ich muss auch sagen dass ich sehr oft
essen gehe vielleicht sogar manchmal ein
bisschen zu oft aber das ist eigentlich
sehr gut für dieses video format und
zwar habe ich mir nämlich gedacht ich
zeig euch einfach mal meine
lieblingsrestaurants wir machen folge
für folge immer ein neues restaurant wo
ich gerne essen gehe
ich zeige euch das ein bisschen zeigen
euch was die da machen zeigt euch die
besitzer zeigt euch das essen zeigt euch
die innenausstattung also einfach so es
geht halt nur und restaurants und heute
fangen wird im ersten an und dafür
müssen wir es los in die innenstadt denn
die warten schon auf uns also würde ich
sagen
los gehts oder also leute die wir sind
jetzt gerade auf dem weg in die stadt
und ich kann ja schon mal sagen warum es
heute ungefähr geht und zwar muss ich
sagen es hat nichts mit burger oder
sonst was zu tun was er sonst vielleicht
von mir gewohnt seit heute wird es
wirklich relativ gesund und zwar machen
die da so pauka balls das ist total habe
ich das richtig
also es hat nichts mit pokémon zu tun
das sind halt so boltz sie kommen aus
vereine also das ist eine hawaiianische
traditionelles gericht und ich muss
sagen ich war das schon sehr oft essen
und es hat mich wirklich überzeugt
deswegen habe ich gedacht das muss ich
mal zeigen und ja deswegen ich bin
gespannt und ihr könnt mir sehr gefällt
dann immer eure meinung dazu in die
kommentare schreiben ob wir so was schon
mal gegessen habt oder ob jetzt mal
testen würde da wir sind in fünf minuten
da okay leute wir sind jetzt hier in der
innenstadt von köln um genau zu sein am
rudolfplatz vielleicht kennt das ja der
ein oder andere von euch ist halt
wirklich zentral und da ist auch schon
der laden um den es heute geht du kannst
ja mal rüber schwenken
[Musik]
wir waren gerade auch schon einmal
kurzen aber ich würde sagen wir gehen
jetzt einfach noch mal rein und dann bin
ich mal gespannt was ihr euch alles
zeigen können also lotto
ja so etwas fähig wollen das ist
vielleicht kommt
ob heute oder ich komme einmal zu zeigen
warum gleich noch mal warum bin ich
hinter der theke und ich gleich gesagt
dass mit dem gehört der laden hier wie
du hast ihn vor zwei drei monaten oder
so erfährt man von magath vor sieben
oder weil sie die polizei
aber ich war das erste mal hier super
200 500 muss sagen ich weiß nicht wo ich
das erste mal hier war mir sofort
gefallen also sieht auf jeden fall sehr
gesund aus und ich bin ehrlich zu dich
vielleicht so ein typ so ich will immer
so gerne mal was essen geht dann ist es
eigentlich immer so ein burger oder so
dann oder keine ahnung presse und das
hier das tier dann bin ich mal ein
bisschen kritisch gewesen und ich muss
wirklich sagen ich habe vorher noch nie
irgendwo sonst
was ich sagen wollte wenn man jetzt
schon mal die chance hat weil ich frage
mich immer wieder dass in so was sonst
abläuft mit diesem bestellt ist und so
werden wir hier potenzial hier drauf
zeigen so zwei geräte und da kann man
jetzt anscheinend immer direkt seine
bestellung rein kommt und dann wird die
abholen
also willkommen die bücherei ist
klingelt einmal jetzt habe ich schon
zwei bestellungen die wird jetzt einmal
einer stunde hier abgeholt hatte und
einmal 116 hat sagt der kunde auch
wir sehen dann möchte jetzt ein gutes
team haben das ist lieferando und hier
ist halt so dass ein komplett 2002
verschiedene und wie viele bestellungen
kommen so rein am tag was du weisst ja
bestimmt so was rekord wurde cook meiner
nase oder nicht auf jeden fall ja so
ungefähr so wie viele stellen genau
richtig gestimmt ich mich dann im
landtag am tag ist ein guter haben aber
im notfall einen sohn verloren haben
noch mal hast du ja ja gut heißt dann
okay eine so sieht es aus dann zeigen
wir euch jetzt einmal das restaurant mit
kurs und da sie auch schon ein paar mal
mit dem vorderrad oder sind dort das
sind 110 quadratmeter hielt
mit einem verrückten einbrechende
ladezeit ich ganz gut geschnittener
paprika winkel was ich gut finde und
noch mit
es ist völlig offen sitzen dann leute er
hier an land ist also wenn es uns
special von uns ja die schau ist ein
sprecher von de maistre noch ein
bisschen verliebt
auf jeden fall diskutiert der erste
laden wo ich mal diese gebäude
probiert habe und ich finde die echtgeld
also das hat mich echt überzeugt sind
also ich habe nicht mehr so tagen habe
ich dadurch die lust am essen da will
ich gar nicht anderes gewesen weil es ja
schon gesünder als 20
viele leute von nadja und haben das war
so ein fragezeichen wird was ist das
überhaupt
wohl aber ist dass wir als lagerist das
heißt quasi der wichtigsten würfel
geschnitten von die zutaten kommen dann
immer so hierzu materialtechnisch
spricht wenn er beliefert die zutaten
kommen ja community verwandten ok fisch
aus dem pazifik wir fangen und jeden
morgen jeden tag geliefert
ich hoffe einfach dass ich und was ist
so das gericht was am meisten mich also
das ist ganz unterschiedlich aber jetzt
zum beispiel viele nehmen die bögen
mauerbau weil dies auch sehr ein
bisschen pikanter und ja also ich
verstehe jetzt mal was neues ich muss
sagen ich komme immer noch gar nicht
dass jetzt online stelle voll voll
entspannter erneut umstellen aber weißt
du aber hier
ich stelle mal nordport großteil also so
heißt das dann kann man selbst
zusammenstellen mit bisschen nehmen was
machst du denn absolute reinheit genau
so schön heißt das ist so der star anne
hathaway ist okay dann einmal dem kreis
der also ich muss sagen er weiß
gezeichneten geheimrezept für oder macht
ihr geheimrezept dazu dann diese jeder
macht und wenn ich jetzt nicht genau
aber nicht viel was genau das ist
eigentlich die geilsten hier peanut
butter tree muss ich sagen also ich weiß
nicht ist das auch die beliebteste kann
ich verstehen ist ein manko nach und
dort reicht mir eigentlich schon also
der wird eine kleine pause
relativ für morgen und der große kater
jetzt noch nicht
[Musik]
und das ist jetzt eine kleinere und was
zahlt man dafür also doch jetzt hat man
jetzt machen würde man 11 euro gezahlt
ok und finde große 12 oder nicht fehlen
der standardgröße haben wir keine großen
kleinen aber ich habe dir bisschen
kleiner
dann würde ich sagen wir sind jetzt
gerne sagt ja okay also leute gebaut das
fertig ich habe mir heute mal gedacht
hey du probierst es auch mit stäbchen zu
essen weil dann ist ja traditionell ich
glaube ich kann das nicht was immer so
nah
irgendwie
[Musik]
und ich sage aber auch mehr auffällt
manchmal ist das werk aber manchmal
nicht kann auch sein dass er manchmal
ein bisschen schärfer
wir haben manchmal ein bisschen schärfer
hören das ging jetzt ist werden jetzt in
soßen wie werden geliefert quasi weil
das ist so ein geheimrezept von maloja
dass die stimme oder sondern haben aber
jetzt einen anderen sohn mohsen gefahren
und schon erst dabei den bestellt haben
dass sie ganz neue arten dazu dass leute
wie ist ganz neu aber ist klar ist
wirklich lecker also ich kann euch das
empfehlen hier mal hin zu gehen lassen
die adressen trieben 24
heute aufgesessen war sehr lecker wie
immer kann ich euch wirklich einmal
vorbei zu führen
ja danke dir ist zeigen
wie gesagt das war jetzt die erste folge
fand ich glaube die leute haben ganz
guten einblick bekommen wenn ihr sagt
mach das mal öfter gemeint welche
restaurants das wir gerne nach oben darf
und schreibt vielleicht neue und
günstige kommentare nun schaut hier
gerne verwalten gesagt riesen du mich
fragst riesen weil friesenwall 24 20 mal
ist alles noch ein bisschen sommer
sichern also ein leichtes essen und dann
geklappt hat oder war es doch damals
wurde er leute was geht ab das video ist
soweit fertig habe es gerade fertig
geschnitten haben schon ein bisschen
später sollen jetzt nur noch mal das
ende aufnehmen weil es für mich sehr
wichtig weil ich halt wirklich richtig
lust aber dieses format weiterzuführen
auch so ein bisschen keine ahnung ich
finde sowas gibt es noch nicht dass
jemand einfach an restaurants geld und
die halt ein bisschen cool darstellt
singen ist für mich super wichtig dass
wenn ihr da auch drauf habt gebt mir
daumen nach oben und wenn ihr vielleicht
ein restaurant in köln habe oder
vielleicht auch das ist doch keine
ahnung schreibt mir gern mal natürlich
muss es auch gut sein ich gucke mir
voran und wenn es mir gefällt dir echt
super gerne im video ansonsten war das
der erste part ich auf heute hat euch
gefallen mit diesen ganzen nahaufnahmen
und bisschen slomo eine mischung aus
japan und juli shirts und essen halt das
musste ich jetzt wirklich noch gesagt
haben und dann alle die sich jetzt
darüber aufregen dass ich das vielleicht
eure meinung nach nur getan um überhaupt
zehn minuten zu kommen das war mir
wirklich sehr wichtig und ich habe aber
auch offen und ehrlich zugeben dass
viele videos von mir manchmal wenn sie
neun minuten 30 gehen
ich schaue dass ich auf zehn minuten
kann ich mache gerade daily da habe ich
an der stützung von zwei leuten dass das
halt auch wirklich immer klappt
natürlich sollen die videos durchgehend
unterhalt seien allerdings war die nicht
dann manchmal das doppelte oder
dreifache wenn sie halt über zehn
minuten gehen deswegen achte immer
darauf videos unterhaltsamen wie du auch
meistens über zehn minuten einfach um
das finanzieren zu können
für euch jeden tag ein video zu machen
und trotzdem selber noch was vom kuchen
ab zu haben sage ich mal so deswegen ich
hoffe ihr versteht dass das war es mit
dem video seid mir nicht böse hört rein
und schaut